i'm bill and this is frank we're here to
answer you guys i'm tommy pope and this
is i'm tommy pope this is
chris o'connor yeah we're from stuff
island we couldn't figure out how to do
that yeah let's take before we settled
on
ruining it yeah
but in a very sexy way uh would you have
sex with a
yes with a dead person for five minutes
if you'd get your laundry done and
folded magically for the rest of your
life no i'd act like an adult
not [ __ ] a corpse and do it myself
i would 100 percent do this
yes does anyone find out
he just sat with you for an hour he's
like he's going to [ __ ] this dead corpse
rather than do anything for himself how
long have they been dead huh
did they just die does it matter yes
they don't have a [ __ ] heartbeat
they've been rotting then i i'll maybe
i'll do the laundry let's say they're in
the morgue
body still like intact maybe they rush
to the morgue they've been sitting in
the balls at dunkin donuts
we got two hungry drivers
we got to get a cream cheese bagel for
this guy because yeah you could have put
dishes you could put anything at the end
of that [ __ ] courts
[ __ ] the corpse because it's magic
you don't have to even it's not like you
get it it's not magic it's a crime
it's a felony stop calling felonies no
the laundry's magic you can't magically
you don't even have to take the laundry
to a yeah it's just clear
you take it off and it's cleaning all
right fold it you're doing the dishes as
soon as we get home
all right you stay over at someone's
house and when you wake up you realize
you pissed in their bed
do you sneak out or tell them i'm
snaking i
this happened to me not that long ago
yeah i was sleeping uh at a girl's place
i snuck out and i [ __ ] a dead woman
and uh you know sometimes you're like
those those nights where you're not even
that drunk when you come home when
you're pissed
no you know what i'm saying luckily i
was sleeping like this like she was
there and i pissed this way
and it just it was soaked over here but
she didn't get wet
and she got up and went to work in the
morning
and i like did the laundry
look at you and then i i
is she in a nice microwave
he's just identifying little items
decent couch i think it was real leather
just start pissing this stuff up
there you go yeah you'll find this in 20
minutes uh would you rather lose half
your dick's length or half your dick's
girth girth easy
uh
more important
yeah i've been getting that feedback
girth is i'm not denying very difficult
are you a girthy guy because like if i
if you have a lot of girth i can give up
yeah i got girth to give i'm going to
give a little couple i'm going to take a
couple inches off yeah i'm going to keep
this i'm going to keep the stump
really yeah
but what if you can't reach the
destination
i'm saying if it's so short you can't
get through the pictures
you know
oh yeah
just back to my size i'm going from a
driver to a three on it
are there sacred days when you refuse to
masturbate funerals tragedies religious
holidays etc god how do you cry without
calling
no i don't yeah that's mandatory getting
up and beating off his mandatory did you
jerk off
3 000 times
[Laughter]
my bed was like a memorial
someone's like tommy tyler only two
thousand died you're like i don't care
ah i need more puffs in here who would
win in a war between all the nyc rats
and pigeons versus all the homeless
people jesus it's really just rats
versus pigeons i don't get the aerial
attack they can [ __ ] you up are we
talking about latinas is this like
actually
rats and pigeons i go i'm team homeless
all the time you think so yeah they're
[ __ ] they don't feel [ __ ] yeah
they're all like they're all dusty yeah
they didn't get directed by a billion
[ __ ] pigs i think there's a lot of
rats
will swarm your bipolar schizophrenic on
meth you could you could send [ __ ]
dinosaurs at this yes
no [ __ ] rubber pellets it would be
nice to see this done on a small scale
just to get it we'll figure it out
we'll look into it you know how how dead
are that
how far are you willing to drive for sex
i've flown like halfway across the
country he was gonna go to san diego
this weekend
sorry about this
does he want air in his laundry like
that
he was going to fly to san diego this
weekend because he got a message on
instagram
and he's like i'm going to go hey why
not yeah what else are you going to do
come on yeah this [ __ ] guy yeah
i don't i'm not getting messages all the
time here
[Laughter]
uh if you had to watch your biggest
enemy [ __ ] the girl of your dreams in
order for you to marry her would you do
it
well my brother is now dating my
ex-girlfriend
so i'll give you this one
no
yeah no
i'd find another person
see
girl of my dream isn't that right yeah
you just find another person and you do
you don't [ __ ] up the dynamic of the
family
and live with your ex-girlfriend there's
tons of people out there
thanksgiving's not the same anymore is
it
find another one
oh [ __ ] good one you don't even need
to be alive
honestly it's not an ex
seriously [ __ ] break up
they [ __ ] live together guys
i hope their house burns down
would you rather have to tell your mom
every everything sexual you've ever done
or have to show her your entire porn
history and show her my porn [ __ ] about
any of those yeah
my mom and i have a great relationship
yeah
would you still afterwards i would be
like i don't jerk off i just you know
i'm just looking at this stuff eat butt
and i've been eating butt for
a decade before it was cool
there was a there was a girl whose ass i
was willing to eat and she didn't want
it
you don't ask yeah
you gotta dive in there dude
yeah
that's just one of those like you
[ __ ] get down there
it's like seeing the no diving in like a
three foot pole like a [ __ ] look at
that i mean a life car you get in there
you ate that ass
i'll put my dick in a shitty ass when i
put my mouth on
who said anything about the [ __ ] you
said you should get down in the muck
it's a clean yeah no you're
my buddy was telling me he drinks so
much coffee shitty ass
you're a scumbag my buddy was telling me
he drinks so much coffee that when he
eats his uh wife's [ __ ] it leaves a
stain on the
on the sheets
what wait what do you think like a brown
stain
from his from his mouth yeah
wait oh what about that
why is everyone getting weird on me
dude he does the [ __ ] all the time where
he's like what's wrong with that
everyone in here is going what the [ __ ]
are you talking i know but i feel like
it's directed at me i don't think the
mouth is leaving the brown
yeah that's not you also like
you don't just start
throwing it up slowly no
all right well maybe you should try it
on the sheets and she was like
no this
is yeah
[Laughter]
all right
internet let us know
mr coffee pot's got to get out of here
uh would you rather [ __ ] the most
hideous girl in the world or an average
looking guy
average looking guy shut up what are you
talking about i
yeah you girl
i'm not against gay listen no
you got to use your imagination i'm
talking like a toothless [ __ ] fat
meth head creature i'll take your
applebees
no you're wrong about this one okay
you want to tell that other story which
story
no
i didn't know
[Laughter]
all right
[Laughter]
cocaine's
who would win in a battle royale 30
midgets versus one full-grown lion
oh why you dude yeah lions [ __ ] one
weapons swiping like dominoes what kind
of weapons
uh they all have like swords but they're
[ __ ] sized swords ah
i think they're live
[Laughter]
because yeah
hey honey piss me one of those [ __ ]
shirts
[ __ ] brutal it's tough as hell so you
mean a knife
[Laughter]
what do you call these days huh would
you rather suck one dick for fifty
thousand dollars or get a thousand
dollars for every dick you suck
well if you're willing i mean you paid
you sucked the packer before yeah yeah
no i go i go a thousand for every dick
you sell yeah because if you're you're
gonna stop
yeah you're getting a pinch yeah yeah
yeah
you don't have to suck a dick you don't
have to suck any dicks yeah you just
find yourself in you know you want to go
on a nice vacation you're just saying
i'm in a jam this month i i can't pay
rent yeah
right right yeah because that's just
like you have a and it's true yeah
always having a dick in your back pocket
you know what i mean yeah and this
doesn't say to completion
oh well that's a bit of a poll i think
we're assuming no no no no you suck the
dick who's reading these cards like a
lawyer
would you rather give the first 90
percent of a [ __ ] or the last 10 10.
you can dodge it you can die
90 of what let's say that's what is it
what are you talking like i would not
like that
five minutes yeah i would think you'd go
ninety nine
shorter time the better well that is the
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
who has the easier job santa claus or
the easter bunny well they're both fake
wait what easter bunny doesn't do [ __ ]
really oh he hides eggs he's a fat
[ __ ] drunk he doesn't make any toys
drives around in the air but he's got to
make the deliveries he doesn't do [ __ ]
dude it's exhausting he's a [ __ ] he's
a new york landlord he doesn't
he just shows up and go yeah we'll get
that fixed sometime
what's your fat kid want a little train
all right
i got [ __ ] all these midgets with
their [ __ ] knives
make it all that's a multivitamin
that came out of your pocket yeah i got
them in there
i take two microdoses two
what is that what is horse i'm just
getting over bronchitis this is a
multivitamin these two are uh you know
jesus christ
in order for you to live you have to
kill a blind child who has the greatest
voice of our generation are you yes yeah
does everyone know that you killed him
yes
but they know that but you don't go to
jail yeah yeah self-defense it's a
written house
chris you're just like excuse me
he was chasing me
[Laughter]
if you could have one person narrate or
do play-by-play of you having sex who
would it be john gruden my dad
your dad
what i'm just yeah i think he's funny
and just hearing him tom do me a favor
don't hit it so hard
why don't you flip her over now she
looks tired tom
it's your turn you're getting coconut
oil everywhere
if you're gonna piss don't piss in your
face
if you could pick one country to run
uh what would it be uh
so i could
be the king of all those bonzos about
like monaco
cappuccino white on the shirt
would you [ __ ] a porn star if afterwards
she had told she had to hold a press
conference on your performance
why do you think i took a couple inches
off baby kept the trunk
what i was saying
yeah no i'm not doing that
no way really no way no way
you don't need butt dude
i would eat butt
she'd be like this i'm not against this
because you never touched
[Laughter]
that's got that right would you rather
be
uh your regular self
without aids or magic johnson
with aids like you can just boom become
magic johnson right now i go i go mj
yeah mj with aids yeah he's the world's
limitless and he he's got enough money
to
curb it you know yeah this hasn't slowed
him down a bit yeah yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna ride this thing out you're gonna
do you yeah yeah yeah yeah
we'll see it could change in a couple
months
all right the holiday season is
approaching all i want for christmas
this year
is youtube subscribers
please we gotta get to a hundred
thousand i want that hundred thousand
subscribers uh we've got a goal for uh
for all you out there for everybody at a
hundred thousand subscribers polly
feitelberg will join us on the show
maybe well if not we'll probably have to
trick her into it but at 100k you will
get poly content so subscribe click the
bell uh icon so you get notifications so
you're always watching leave a comment
below talk about it post about it spread
word tell your friends tell your friends
100 000 subscribers on kfc radio for
polly feidelberg let's make it happen